on the show we've been following what's
been going on with net neutrality at the
FCC and it's hard to think of in
addition to health care an issue that
touches more aspects of our day-to-day
lives in so many ways every single day
than Internet freedom and net neutrality
and I've told you about the new FCC
chairman appointed by the president Ajit
PI who has vowed to undo really
important regulations from two years ago
protecting net neutrality this includes
a rule that would classify Internet
service providers as public utilities
really important thing under title 2 of
the Telecommunications Act and require
them to be regulated as public utilities
this prevents actions such as Internet
service providers choosing to slow down
certain connection speeds for certain
websites and certain services if maybe
it benefits them financially many people
probably most people I would say don't
live in areas with much or any
competition as far as Internet service
providers are concerned so if these
regulations are removed many people will
have no choice but to either have their
internet access manipulated by the one
carrier in town if you want Internet at
all or to not have internet at home
we've talked about how big Internet
service providers like Comcast have been
publishing propaganda in support of the
removal of these net neutrality rules
because net neutrality would mean more
regulations for them and potentially
lower profits but many internet content
providers are now rallying behind net
neutrality and they're opposing the
elimination of these regulations and
that's a really good thing there's been
a national day of action planned in
support of keeping open Internet rules
intact and many web-based companies are
planning to support and participate in
it among these companies are Amazon Etsy
Kickstarter Mozilla reddit Vimeo more
companies are expected to join michael
chiha vimeos head lawyer said quote net
neutrality made it possible for Vimeo
along with countless other startups
to innovate and thrive the FCC's
proposed rollback of the 2015 open
Internet rules threatens to impede that
innovation and allow a handful of
incumbent ISPs to determine winners and
losers it's being backed by the ACLU by
the Center for Media justice by
Greenpeace by moveon.org this actually
matters and it has worked there was a
similar day of protest you might recall
in 2014 and it was backed by Internet
content providers not service providers
and it helped give us the current net
neutrality regulations which are by the
way in danger now that's what we're
talking about so we can actually say
with some confidence Pat that when the
population of the u.s. mobilizes around
a movement like this it can actually
have an impact it's also very
interesting to how you don't really know
which content providers would stand to
benefit yeah if net neutrality was kept
in place or eliminated sure I mean you'd
have to imagine there's a PR angle maybe
they're part of some other corporate
conglomerate that also includes telecom
companies but established companies like
Amazon you wouldn't think they would
necessarily want to keep net neutrality
because as the guy from Vimeo said it
allows smaller companies to compete yeah
so there's no it's not a foregone
conclusion that the companies I listed
Amazon Etsy et cetera would necessarily
be behind this in case in point Netflix
I believe I'm just thinking about this
now we can we can fact check it after I
believe in Netflix at one point was much
more vocally in favor of net neutrality
and they're not against it now but
they're sort of like not really getting
too involved in it at this point you
know even now on the first layer if it
costs them some money for the PR
perspective it helps them a great deal
and you have a fox watching the henhouse
here Ajit PI who now runs the FCC
appointed by Trump is a former Verizon
lawyer what that's why it's especially
important that people become engaged in
this and when John Oliver's episode
about net neutrality and recently the
Kahn sending comments to the FCC aired
it crashed the FCC website due to
traffic the FCC said that five million
comments have been filed on the matter
at least partially connected to that
story that John Oliver did it was also
great just to see him humiliate a GPI
and have
that Reese's mug that was much bigger
than the one he has Reese's that's the
other one we're putting on the list of
interesting pronunciations from Pat I
know a lot of people who say Reese's
Reese's peanut butter cups
Reese's or Reese's how about the same
thing well you know it's a cyst tomahto
tomato I call it so there have been that
many announcements about exactly what
will happen on July 12th this day of
action but all of these supporting
internet content providers are going to
have some kind of messaging on that day
similar to the SOPA blackout in 2012
I really am disappointed that this has
become a partisan issue when you think
about all of the implications a small
number of big companies have effectively
an Oleg Apple II on something as
essential as Internet infrastructure and
we're opening the door to them being
able to choose which websites can you
visit at normal speed and which websites
can you visit at a lesser speed and how
well you're able to access what and when
based on financial interests and
business relationships and a lot of what
Donald Trump and his appointees are
tackling only has an upside for big
corporations and their executives not
people but yet if Trump's name is on it
you will have trumpets that support it
even if it's not good for them yeah I
think the financial interests is part of
the reason why this will never be a
settled issue it's kind of like a Hydra
that keeps coming back in different
forms every few years
nice imagery I like that a Hydra what
can you do sign up at battle for the
Netcom if Google Fiber is available in
your area sign up for it and bail on
your ISP the real problem though is that
too many areas have no competition at
all right I guess there you could work
towards municipal broadband but that's
an uphill battle there is another angle
though to the competition if you can get
more competition from Internet service
providers to pick Amazon because they're
on this list Amazon could refuse to
service one Internet service provider
and practically put him out of business
imagine for a second right this is
impractical I mean it's basically
impossible currently but imagine if
there was a city where you had Comcast
Verizon Google Fiber or whatever let's
say there were five options and Comcast
takes an anti net neutrality stance
Amazon could say if our website
determines that you're on Comcast
the connection won't work now it could
be self-sabotage because Amazon doesn't
want to lose the customers that are
getting on they're on their platform
from Comcast
but I'm just sort of proposing that
these content providers could have major
power over ISPs yeah I see what you're
saying with the example but of course
the telecom company could turn around
and say well we support local buyers
then instead of big conglomerates like
yes they could it could backfire it
could absolutely backfire but just an
idea anyway battle for the Netcom check
it out